hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb Denby and today we're
gonna be taking a look at a game between
Jew and Jun and Chris yep from this
year's Karan's Cup so it's actually kind
of the story of the tournament a Chrissa
hip actually managed to take down the
women's world champion in this game and
kind of ruined her chances of getting
first place in the tournament
why don't we take a look and see how she
did it of course the game started with E
4 E 5 Knight f3 knight c6 and now after
Bishop b5 a6 Bishop a4 we have the Roy
Lopez and here Chris I actually chose to
do a pretty interesting line that is
kind of growing in popularity lately and
it's this move g6 that she chose to play
this has definitely been seen before but
really it's it's on the rise currently
so if it's new to you be sure to check
it out with both sides both colors here
it's important to know the idea of being
black usually or white is usually trying
to play this move d4 and so black is
just gonna put this bishop on this long
open diagonal and try to make use of the
bishop in that sense players such as
shocked mom in Europe have actually been
playing this recently but let's continue
so d4 is played immediately in this case
this isn't the main move usually white
tries this move c3 or gets Castle before
opening it up quite so early but d4 is
fine we see II takes d4 now white
actually does continue with c3 offering
up the pawn in this case though black
declines it simply developing the Bishop
to g7 instead now white regains her pawn
and black expands on the Queen side with
the move b5 after Bishop b3 we see black
develop with 9 g e7 of course you don't
really want to play Knight f6 block in
this Bishop you'd also be walking into
this move e5 so the e7 square it is for
this night now white tries to make use
of black not taking any claim in the
center by playing the move d5
getting even more space now black
continues with Knight a5 and now we see
Bishop d2 this Knight captures on b3 and
this Queen captures on b3 and this is
still definitely a well known
territory in fact received Dhirubhai Lee
has actually had a couple games in this
line but it seems to have two scores
pretty well for white historically that
being said definitely black isn't doing
too badly here I think blacks position
is totally fine there's a couple main
moves that been played castles is
totally fine for black d6 has also been
played keeping an eye on the e5 square
but in the game Chris to get shows a
third option which is c5 the Smoove of
course taking queenside space as quickly
as she can not allowing white any time
to try and prevent these moves
immediately c5 the downside to this move
is that after Bishop c3 for one your
bishops attacked and for two this EA v
square is starting to to look a little
bit under defended if black isn't
careful here white might just try to
roll over the center with this move e5
and then looking at moves like e6000 the
black pieces because of this black
actually plays a pretty unorthodox move
here Ben Feingold fans will will go
crazy black please f6 it's actually kind
of the only move for black here the idea
being one you keep your powerful Bishop
on the long open diagonal and two you're
keeping an eye on this g5 squared you're
not allowing white this very important
pawn break and with that in minds white
actually plays this move a 3 here the
idea is to prevent this move b4 from
kicking this bishop off of its natural
square but now this Lee gives black the
time to play d6 and firmly clamp down on
this a 5 squared making sure why it's
not breaking through in the center just
yet now white continues with this move
h4 just trying to put some pressure on
charissa Chris it doesn't flinch though
in fact castles into the Kings side
despite this Age pawn coming down the
board white takes the time to finish
your development we now see a slightly
strange move Queen e8 perhaps rerouting
to this f7 Square perhaps just putting
some more pressure on this week a pawn
perhaps preparing for moves such as f5
in the future white castles black plays
Bishop d7 supporting this beep on
further preparing some queenside
advances white goes head with Queen c2
and now is where Carissa starts to go
just a little bit wrong really a black
would love to be expanding on the Queen
side like this
and in order to do that the a file quite
often opens up and because of that black
might want to be keeping this rook on a
a just so it can contest this file
pretty naturally pretty easily without
too much difficulty also if you notice
there's really one main problem piece in
Black's camp here and it's this night on
e7 this night is not helping any of
blacks plans in fact it's really in
blacks way blocking this Queen from from
eyeing this efile so perhaps the best
move here is actually to play something
like Knights e8 maybe white will play a
move like b3 giving this bishop some
space you can play Knight b6 and very
naturally bring this night to support
the Queen side in addition you're
opening up this Queen as I said and
black is doing just fine in this
position instead though we see Chrissa
bring the rook to c8 and this move
doesn't make a whole lot of sense to me
this trick really belongs on a 8 and the
c8 square would been much better served
for this Knight white does continue with
B 3 and now carissa goes for h6 keeping
an eye on the g5 square perhaps I'm once
again these f5 breaks that is something
this knight on e7 can do but the problem
is these things are coming a little bit
too slow because now that black has
diverted her rook from the a file light
takes the opportunity to actually
challenge her on the Queen side with the
move a for preparing to open things up
and now Krista actually kind of admits
her mistake and brings the rook back to
the a file so pretty clearly the move
Knight to c8 might have been a bit
better there white does open the a file
with a takes b5 Chris obliges with a
takes b5 we see the trade of rooks and
now white brings their other rook over
to the a file and we see Queen b7 from
Karissa preparing to challenge this file
and here white played a very natural
move but it turns out to just be the
wrong the wrong way to go in this case
the the right way to play is also fairly
natural and it's a little bit more
common
in these types of structures where you
see black expanding on the queenside
like this so let you at home try and
find the best move to slow down black's
pawn rush on the queenside here well
called a pawn rusher or space gaining
adventure over here for black you want
to slow it down and you want to claim
some space for yourself see how you can
do it
alright hopefully at home you guys found
the move it's just before before really
challenges these these black pawns in an
uncomfortable way probably you should be
playing c4 but now these pawns are well
blockaded the one pawn in this white
bishop do a nice job of stopping these
pawns in their tracks and perhaps b5 is
going to prove to be a little bit of a
weakness you can imagine wreck a5 coming
on the board soon and if black does play
move like okay now we can support this
this rook from behind with a move like
Queen a two or even Queen B 2 putting
pressure on the Kings side we'll stick
with Queen a2 and you can imagine now
even moves like B takes a5 coming on the
board and these pawns are actually under
just a little bit of pressure you can't
really be pushing to be four just yet
because I'll play a six and eventually
you're gonna have to divert your Queen
and lose this pawn and so this past a
pawn would give white some really nice
chances here thanks to the space she
gains with B floor instead though she
plays the natural but not so good
Queens a2 and then very naturally the
way to refute this is to play the move
first b4 and now after Bishop b2 you can
reroute your pieces in any number of
ways towards this Queen side and what I
could be doing fine once again Crysta
chose a different path which is also
okay for black just to play Knight see
it immediately and now b4 actually hits
with much less impacts because black can
actually ignore it and just play Knight
b6 and while this does look slightly
scary this is in fact totally fine for
for the black player here so instead of
before we actually see 91 from June June
bringing this night to help in the Queen
side but now after b4 Bishop b2 we see
Bishop b5 activating the bishop the
knight c2 and now actually Bishop d3
so we see because white didn't play be
for black played be for herself and use
this to activate her Bishop along these
light squares now after night III
Christa brings her Queen over to e7 once
again putting more pressure on this week
eeep on and we see that the white major
pieces on the a file really didn't
manage to achieve anything
despite their total dominance over this
file in fact this square is covered by
this bishop this square is covered by
this tonight and the a8 Square is more
or less useless as soon as your queen
jumps there this Knights able to jump
elsewhere perhaps in and attack the
Queen and really this Queen isn't isn't
making any threats from a a so very
instructive stuff from charissa allowing
her opponent this a file but ensuring
that it isn't useful instead creating
threats elsewhere June when June was now
forced to bring her rook back off of the
a file to help defend against some of
these threats Carissa brings her knight
to a very natural b6 square and now
after Queen a1 it is now actually
Karissa who controls the a file so very
uh you know instructive maneuvering
there from Karissa creating threats
where the white major piece is kind of
abandoned and then using those threats
to gain control the a file for herself
this Queen now steps to c1 and we see
black play this move h5 just locking
this pawn on this dark square and
perhaps in fact allowing this Bishop an
extra opportunity to get active white
now plays the move Knight to c4 and that
is this one I believe opening up this
rook and taking use or making use of the
C 4 square but actually after Knight
takes and Knight takes now this truck
does come into a useful square on a 2
and white is in quite serious danger
here due to the just the sheer activity
of the black pieces white continues with
g3 just trying to solidify things a
little bit we see King aged seven kind
of forcing through this Bishop h6 idea
Knight d2 from white we see Bishop h6
from black and this game is is kind of
over white is is totally lost here
perhaps white missed the opportunity
though
play the move rookie 3 when after a
bishop ate six white will play f4 and
while Krista has a few opportunities
here you can kind of take an extra pawn
if you like but now white also has some
opportunities to get back into the game
with moves like Queen b1 taking
advantage of some nasty tactics here and
so white might have been able to get
just a little bit back into the game
using this night on c4 putting more
pressure here and using these tactical
ideas along the e-file but instead we
did see Knight d2 when after Bishop h6
f4 now the white the black Queen rather
is not tied to this pawn because this
Queen has moved so we can see Queen a7
come onto the board why it tries to
bring your knight back to c4 but it's
just a bit too late now we see Queen d7
which is a better square for the Queen
eyeing these squares on the Kings side
rookie three from White's but now Bishop
takes c4 takes the knight off the board
now the night is gone the queen is free
to move once again we see Queen g4 the
King comes to h1 and now the sacrifice
of the game we see Bishop takes f4 and
after G takes f for this queen is just
wreaking havoc on the Queen side with
all of these ponds falling in short
order in the game the Queen step to b1
and Krista played the nice move rook
takes b2 with a clearly winning endgame
here not much left to be done in this
game besides win it so that's exactly
what Chris it did June when June tried
to pick up this pawn but after Queen
takes d4 check and b3 this pawn is
running up the board Jew and June gave a
few checks with Queen f8 check and Queen
D a check but now after King f5 Queen d7
king he 5 Queen g7 king f4 Queen f6 King
g4 Queen e6 check queena
5 Queen takes d6 we saw Queen f2 check
King H 1 Queen f3 king age 2 Queen age 3
King G 1 and then to round out the game
we see the nice move Queen g3 forking
the king and queen 4
a trade and now black will be promoting
with checkmate and this is where Jew and
June actually threw in the towel right
after Queen g3 check and so a very nice
game by charissa yep a game where she
actually outmaneuvered the Women's World
Champion nah not an easy task by the
sixteen-year-old from America and I
forgot what I was gonna say Danny so I'm
just gonna take a second here come up
with a conclusion to this game let's see
okay and this game really shows the
importance of keeping your opponent's
pawn pushes at bay not allowing them to
take more space to activate their pieces
white missing this opportunity with b4
losing control of the game and finding
her pieces on the a file simply
misplaced well done to Chrissy yet for
taking out the women's world champion
once again
thank you for joining me this has been
brain review and I will see you in the
next episode